this is a repost of the interview with
tom delong and jim semivan from
professor brian keating's podcast into
the impossible which took place on
august 12 2021. tom delong is the
co-founder of the rock band blink 182 as
well as the more pertinent to the stars
academy which investigates ufos jim
semivan is also a founding member of the
to the stars academy as well as being a
former employee of the cia for 25 years
brian keating is an experimental
physicist who has a channel interviewing
various nobel prize winners among others
which can be found at youtube.com
dr brian keating links are in the
description and i recommend you
subscribe to his content many haven't
seen this conversation so i'm reposting
here with improved audio timestamps and
a minor amount of extra footage if you'd
like to see more conversations like this
then do consider supporting at
patreon.com
kurt jaimungle as the sponsors and the
patrons are the only reason i'm able to
do this full time
thank you and enjoy this holiday morsel
of a repost a conversation with kurt
jaimungle tom delong jim semivan and the
renowned professor of physics brian
keating i think i i think i know how to
do it
i have through i'm always a bit
concerned because sometimes
when i live stream it shows me a
previous stream and so i asked the
audience can you please and i asked him
to say a unique word like let's say
pokemon or bulbasaur
because then i know okay you're seeing
this one so there's 204 people waiting
that's cool
210 wow that's nice that's big for me
it's small for kurt
now are you is there anything off limits
uh jim like luella zondo is that okay to
talk about or
oh no losing a great guy we we
luke chris we're all buddies and and we
we talk a lot haven't talked to lou
though in about a month chris smelling
and i probably every every few days
we're exchanging emails so uh-huh okay
the only thing i can get into is um
any any detailed questions on cia what
cia is doing sure
half of my questions man
yeah right i mean i mean that's why i
have it on a lot of these shows i i mean
i don't i don't like saying things like
i can't talk about it i can't tell you
it just sounds so awful right and uh
so i've tried to avoid it but
and as much as possible
jim you also mentioned that
both
brian and myself come recommended
by who
just friends of mine in the community uh
i mean you know i'm not talking to any
senior government officials saying let's
listen to these guys but now just
friends in the community it's they said
that you know if you're going to get on
something you want to do something with
uh you know credibility and good
reputation this is where you want to go
wow wow wow that's a huge huge
compliment
well
you know it's i think it's true so yeah
and now it's it and brian i i heard of
you too a long time ago you know i
actually did a recruiting uh session out
at university of california san diego
back in
i think 2 000 and
gosh one or two
yeah out there oh cool i was under a
name
i was using a fake name
you know and
i was recruiting for the clandestine
service and uh what a great group of
students you had though yeah we have
some great students and good patriots
there yeah it's really great i'm glad to
glad to hear that next time you're in
town let me know or next time i come out
to the loophole state of delaware
we'll be ready to go so what we're going
to do
is uh we're going to introduce ourselves
we're going to talk a little philosophy
uh so i'll start first kurt will go next
jim will go next and then you go
and like kind of what your mission is in
life and kind of description how you got
involved in this i'll say some words of
platitudes in the beginning and you know
our goal is to be discuss things not
debate i think debate is pointless
people get all admired in in accusations
and whatever so i just want to have it
be high level discussion for the benefit
of humanity okay
okay
all right man so we're gonna go live if
i can get this all set up
preparing this meeting as being live
stream got it yep
hopefully this will work
and we'll shoot out to the internet kirk
can you check the live stream is working
on urine
take approximately 15 seconds
welcome everybody to a very special
conversation between
three of my friends
some more
uh older friends than uh than others but
we are undergoing a debate a
conversation rather not a debate i think
most debates are pointless
but discussion is very valuable
and we've had a lot of interest in
getting together members
of different communities communities
from academia represented by me from the
military represented by jim or the
government from by jim and from lay
people who have really been responsible
for getting
this excitement this attention that this
subject needs out to the public and of
course that's speaking of tom delong
who's joining us from to the stars
academy
now jim is joining us from the east
coast jim uh seven and my friend kurt
jaymungel who runs a wonderful channel
which you should all subscribe to call
theories of everything i've been a guest
many other guests had on people from
louie elizondo to many others in this
community i'm more of a neophyte novice
and i'm more interested in
doing what galileo said so my hero as
everybody knows who subscribes to my
channel is galileo galilei here's a
finger puppet we're gonna get one of tom
and jim at some point galileo said uh
let us measure what is measurable and
make measurable what is not and i'm
pleased to say i have become a member of
the galileo project at harvard
university which just started just about
a couple weeks ago i'm on their
scientific advisory board and i joined
that not because i have so much free
time as the chancellor's professor of
physics at uc san diego and the
co-director of the arthur c clark center
for human imagination but because i
think this is a very very important
subject not the least of which because i
hope to learn some of the physics of the
advanced future if indeed we are being
visited by
a an advanced extraterrestrial
civilization or perhaps as tom calls
them threats in either case
i think it's fascinating so i'd love to
introduce today
my guest and uh first to confirm that uh
my friend kurt is out there and he can
hear us kurt can you please uh can you
please introduce yourself and your
channel
sure my name is kurt jaimungal i'm a
filmmaker with a background in math and
physics i'm particularly interested in
the theoretical ends of physics
something called theories of everything
the channel that i host podcasts on is
called theories of everything
essentially what are the fundamental
laws of the universe investigating that
as well as the possible connection those
laws have to consciousness and free will
and even god
my interest in ufos is because there
seems to be an intimate tie between ufos
and consciousness there's almost a
direct tie between physics and ufos
because they defy
our known laws and i'm interested in it
i happen to think that innovation will
come from the fringes rather than the
the center or at least be informed by
the fringes
yeah thank you kurt and i want to remind
people who want to leave questions
please put it in the live chat we are
live it is thursday
2 38 p.m in the pacific time zone uh
next up is jim a semi-van who has a very
very impressive biography but i thought
maybe he could introduce himself and
talk about maybe how he came to come to
know tom
oh well thank you very much and thank
you very much for having me on your
program um i've heard about you and uh
i'm really happy to be here
um
i i met tom gosh what it was about five
years ago tom um
yeah
there was a group of uh
uh
i'd say intelligence community defense
department people that studied this
topic for a long time
uh very informally and unofficially um
and uh we had got together i got a phone
call from one of them one day and he
said uh do you know this fella named tom
delong and i said no he said blink 182.
i said no doesn't ring any bells
he said well he wrote a book called
secret machines chasing shadows and
there's a lot of information in that
book
um
that
that is
well
running true to form and and it we don't
know whether or not some of the
information on
some of the programs that the us
government had was being leaked or not
and we knew that tom
well at least i was told that tom had a
lot of senior
uh government officials that he was in
touch with his his advisors
uh so i we took it upon ourselves to go
talk to mr julen
and uh and i was the one basically uh
asked why don't you figure it out you
know you're you're the you're the
operations officer you know you did this
for a living so i had a really nice i
flew out to san diego and had a very
very nice chat with tom and it became
apparent right away that uh tom um not
only being a very nice guy but extremely
bright guy but he had put together
all this data that he had been hearing
and listening to and actually two and
two came out to four i was rather
surprised clearly there was no leak of
that classified information as far as i
was concerned but tom sort of hit the
nail on the head
so i then we had i think breakfast the
next day with uh some other people dr
put off and i won't name the other
people that were there they may not want
their names known but uh luminaries in
the field um
and that's when we started uh tom asked
me if we could
maybe
work with him onto the stars and we
agreed to do that and then i think tom
we sketched out a uh
uh what to the stars uh would look like
on a cocktail napkin there and uh and
that was it we shook hands and uh we've
been uh friends ever since uh uh and uh
so it was a lot of fun
great uh that's great to hear and
actually jim i'm sorry tom this will
probably hurt your ego a lot uh but uh
but they they my audience and kurt's
audience are really like they're
impressed that you're on tom but they're
like we really want to hear from jim so
yeah
all of us are the same way it's the
first time in my life anybody wanted to
hear from me but all right yeah so tom
you uh have many distinctions of course
your guitarist and and you could
probably be on the beach here in san
diego and next time we got to do this in
person down up in encinitas or wherever
but uh but you could spend your whole
days you know cashing royalty checks
from your awesome musical career and yet
you don't do that you don't rest on your
laureate laurel so to speak and you've
taken on this new mission and really you
know i have to confess um you know in
the beginning when i first heard i was
like why is this guy interested he's not
a scientist he's not a military pilot uh
but you actually made this into an issue
i don't have to say more than almost
anyone in popular culture you've made
this an issue why is this so important
to you
you know i've always been fascinated
with like kind of why we're here and
what this is all about anybody
that has any kind of similar wiring to
me
would understand you know growing up in
a broken family and like
i got kicked out of high school you know
i just read a lot of bad tough kids and
and i and my parents didn't get along
you know and i just looked around a lot
and i said this doesn't make any sense
to me like really like somehow by
accident or
some weird design like i'm just supposed
to only care about my bickering family
and my my school that i didn't really
fit into and go and get a job that i
hate so i kind of started early on on a
quest of like not being like my parents
you know and and working for myself and
i was i was an artist i wanted to create
things but as an artist you know
you want people to emotionally get moved
by the art that you're creating the
whole good job of an artist is to digest
the world
and with your point of view you kind of
regurgitate it back to somebody then
they get to digest it and hopefully they
they see other points of view i mean
that's what we do that is our job
description so when i looked around i
was like none of this makes sense you
know what what really moves me would be
like what's the layer deeper than all
this and that's when i started realizing
that there's an entire like kind of
esoteric study out there that deals with
consciousness and ufos and you know
cosmology and all these different things
but really when you when you get into
ufos at first it's fascinating at first
it's like oh my god conspiracy theory
you know this is fun and then you start
kind of going wait some of this [ __ ] is
like real there's no way there's an
astronaut here there's like a president
there's like you know director of the
cia or some admiral and you're kind of
going
wait a second and then you start diving
deeper and then when you dive deeper i
always tell people it's you're not
studying like events really i mean those
are fun and you get into those the first
few years but really if you study this
subject you're you're like jim said it's
like you know you're getting into
quantum mechanics and you're getting
into consciousness and you're looking at
archaeology differently and petroglyphs
and stuff and you're starting to really
soak in all the branches of the tree um
and it seemed to me that all those
things combined it really created a glue
in my mind at least that tied together
so many disparate ends of what mankind
is all about and what's been going on it
almost fit like a perfect puzzle piece
not that i know
everything i don't know if anyone does
but for me and and it just became very
um evident that this was like oh my this
is a puzzle piece that fits it fits in
all these things that i grew up you know
um having interactions with from like
religion to
government national security stuff to
advance technology stuff to the history
of mankind and so on and i'm still on
that quest
but um
on another note it's the only thing that
ever took me out of the maddening kind
of obsession of trying to write a better
song like when you're in a band it's
or you're painting a painting any kind
of art it's only going to be as good as
how much time you can put into it and um
so what you end up doing is putting all
your time into it especially if you work
for yourself it's like your wife's like
joining the family and you're at playing
guitar at one in the morning go no i got
to figure out this melody well this is
like the one thing that got me out of
that because i i need to learn all the
time
i don't really like
like predictable movies i don't like
normal fiction books and stuff but this
was like a fiction story
but that has a bunch of things you can
learn it's like it's just as fascinating
but you can really enrich your mind and
soul by diving into some of these
branches of the tree you know so
here i am 20 years later i put some good
pieces together um
but
as jim will tell you the first day i met
jim i was like thank god you know he's
like
who are you and what are you doing and
i'm like i'm looking for somebody to
work with me i i think we can do
something great for the world i just
don't really know how to do it by myself
i need
i need some help and and thankfully
jim and a bunch of the people that he
knew and was working with felt the same
way it's
it was just a good time to come together
do you ever get um you know kind of the
i'm sure you've had your share of of
negative influences maybe people that
don't like you in some way for your
music or your or this research do you
find any commonalities though in kinds
of the support or maybe the negative
attention that you get uh because you
know on the face of it yes there are
aspects of it but i would think naively
scientists pilots etc we'd be the most
interested but you made the interesting
point that it's part of culture and
people don't appreciate that science is
a form of culture too
uh equal in every respect in my opinion
uh to arts and you know and letters and
so forth so do you find commonality
there tom just from the two different
careers that you've had
um i do i mean
you know it's funny like one of the one
of the when i was working with um
and when i was building relationships
with people before i knew jim that were
you know high-ranking former government
officials or military people and stuff i
remember i wanted to thank them um for
their time listening to me you know and
so
one way to thank them that i came up
with was in
the government kind of military
industrial complex world they all create
these challenge coins have you ever seen
the challenge coins where you got one
here yeah i've got it you got one there
well for the people watching it's like
you know these little coins that have
like your platoon name on there maybe
the things you believe in maybe it's the
operation you're a part of
yeah here's one uh from my buddy in
afghanistan yeah they all make um um
there you go
so these little coins you bring them out
of bars and you owe each other drinks
depending on who's got a better coin or
whatever so i decided to make a
challenge point and i put on the
vitruvian man which was uh da vinci's
you know
two arms two you know or four armed four
legs kind of thing but what that stood
for was art and science and what i
really liked about that and this all
comes full circle to your question was
um art and science to me was something
measurable with something that's
infinite you know it's consciousness and
zeros and ones to some degree but when
they come together um i think for the
longest time we've always separated
consciousness and things that we don't
understand and we put it in religion we
just go that's god's world so we can't
know that we can't measure that um yeah
there you go and um and so consciousness
in metaphysics and things we don't
understand was supernatural paranormal
um and it was in the realm of the old
testament or something you know um or
other religions um but the vitruvian man
this idea of bringing consciousness and
science or art and science together
because art is really just a stream of
consciousness you're making things up so
the question is is where are you getting
that you know you're you're some type of
antenna and you're pulling it from
consciousness in my view um so i use
this on a challenge point to say look as
an artist
and as something that's scientifically
based here if we can merge these
together the future of science i think
is going to be once we understand
consciousness we take the the realm of
what used to be all religion or
something and we merge it with science
and now we got like this theory of
everything um so i wanted to say that my
my um
project was that it was an artist
working with things that are tangible
tangible and measurable and so i made
these challenge coins i put the
vitruvian man on there um and i gave
them to everybody and and um for me i
got the same rush
as being an artist but with this because
i really felt that i was
i was
putting something together with a point
of view that people
really haven't been able to spend time
with or study or look at or notice um
and it became kind of like the guiding
north star the light you know was the
merging of these two things um and it's
just been a hell of a lot of fun along
the way i believe it kurt uh would you
like to ask uh you had some comments and
questions for jim do you want to take it
from here
yeah
first i want you
tom and jim and the audience to know
that i'm not a skeptic nor a debunker
i'm more of a
i'm curious and i'm clueless
when i research this topic i'm just
baffled and bewildered constantly i
don't know what to think
so when i spoke to travis walton
recently some people thought that i was
a skeptic that's actually not true i i'm
asking detailed questions because i want
to know what was the air like on this
alien ship i want to know what did the
glass rod feel like was it heavy was
gravity the same and so on so if i ask
you detailed questions please it's out
of a place of love
i'm curious to know about skinwalker
you're asking jim right
i can ask you whoever wants to answer
what's going on with skinwalker and
what's its connections to
what's its connection to ufos
uh
well i am by no means an ex expert on
skinwalker ranch uh tom and i know
uh all the people that are involved
george uh calm uh kelleher and george
knapp keller her uh i've never met mr
bigelow i was supposed to at one point
but it never never happened but um
uh there is
i think that that's a fascinating case
uh the
uh i think but i i don't know whether i
can actually discuss that in any kind of
meaningful way because i wasn't there
and i wasn't part of it i read the book
like everybody else i john alexander's a
dear friend of mine and you know he was
there and we talk about it quite a bit
um i think uh what had happened there uh
was true and accurate and real
uh but i also believe that when you go
looking
for the phenomenon
uh it basically doesn't show itself uh
it doesn't like to do that and after 40
years of studying that
you know it's it's that low
observability thing going on you know
why we can never get a good picture of
uap for some strange reason it doesn't
want to go there so you mentioned
earlier you're dazed and confused well
yeah i'm about as dazed as confused as
you are by the whole thing i have my own
opinions based on what i know and based
on what i've read but um
skinwalker is fascinating i i you know
from everybody i know that been there
and done that including
some people that were not mentioned in
the book which i don't want to get into
but uh
it's uh it's a pretty serious place and
a lot of serious things happen there
um
but i'll let tom go
go and talk more about that
sure you know i what i find fascinating
about skinwalker is that um you
basically have the convergence of
multiple
you know
things happening you know so when you
look at ufos you can find stories where
somebody might come out and their cattle
are missing or
there's um
you know a cattle mutilation where blood
is gone or parts of the jar are
dissected maybe an eyeball's gone maybe
the reproductive reproductive organs are
gone or whatever um and in a lot of like
really
weird things about it like maybe the
cuts are in between cells maybe there's
no vascular collapse maybe it happened
within 10 minutes when the farmer turned
around or something then you have um
people that might have seen lights in
the sky the day the night before when it
happened or you know then there's people
that have paranormal feelings they might
have seen
like you know some type of entity that's
invisible or something they weren't
quite sure
then you have poltergeist events and
other houses whatever but what's weird
about skinwalkers they were all
happening there you know so you have all
these things happening in one location
but as jim said it's like
super elusive um it's almost like it'll
watch you be there for a week and then
the night you're driving away to go home
it's like you look at your rear view
mirror and there's something crazy you
know and it almost toys with you that
was something that they all seem to say
like it seemed like it knew
that you wanted to see something you
want to do something whatever what i
find fascinating is that you have this
one location where so many things are
happening and it's documented by a bunch
of government people a bunch of phd
scientists a bunch of people that have
lived there and um and not only
documented over like a few months we're
talking like decades you know
and it's kind of a hot spot where you
can kind of dig into
trying to find why are they all
happening at this one location and and
what interests me is that i think it
gives us a potential pathway to discuss
some
alternate um
candidates for where they're from or
what they're doing or how it all works
like i think most people like to think
of ufos is they're coming from another
planet you know we found an exoplanet
and it's coming there and how do they
travel well they could do it in 30 years
if they go fast well the data doesn't
seem to suggest that really it it's more
what's happening at skinwalker where it
seems like
it's more about frequencies and
dimensional or they materialize it's
almost like their displacement craft
that displaces our time like a submarine
would in the ocean um and that was a lot
of what dr halpudoff worked on on atip
was understanding the attributes of the
propulsion and the science that they're
using and i think once you think about
ufos using that kind of a technology
then it's kind of like well if they do
that if they use that that means there's
things that are adjacent to us
that we don't see we don't understand
but are like right here and every once
in a while they can kind of cross over
is it because we're aware of it and can
see it and that opens it or is it
because it's a geomagnetic
area where where those types of things
are have an easier time coming through
um or is it everywhere and we just think
it's in one location i don't know i mean
there's a story that even happened there
where they like you know they were there
and they and you're talking about
government
grade phds where they watch
you know something in the atmosphere
open up and something come through not
sure what it is and and it was a huge
event so they run down to grab the
cameras and see what was on the cameras
they open up these lock boxes and then
like all the electronics are missing and
the cameras and they're like wait what
like these were locked up and who took
it's like a game and so it gets really
interesting where
is it a game i don't know but it might
be a consciousness thing and so
i get passionate about a place like that
because it gives you the ability to do
to really jump into some wild stuff i
mean one of the scientists there
was walking through a field
and they basically saw um you know they
saw they walked past um
like a cow or something and then they
turn around it was gone
and then like 10 minutes later they're
like where is it they turn back around
and there it is on the ground just out
of nowhere with like two broken legs so
they run in the ground
for life
it was no it was alive you know and then
they run back into
the the house to go grab a gun or
something to take care of it and when
they come out now it has four broken
legs you know or something it's like
creepy and and and like causing
alarm because
number one it makes no sense number two
it's like it's happening so quick that
they can't even um and i got family
showing up from the beach you know you
see people behind me but um you
mentioned the beach they all went to the
beach earlier but um
what it seems to be is that it's it's
you know an issue with
time
um and an issue with
moving it like from here to here where
we can't see it and back and then people
see crap and then i don't know it's
it's just wild and it and it's so
fascinating and i always tell people in
hollywood because you know to the stars
is getting into making like
movies and tv series and documentaries
and stuff and i just you don't need to
sensationalize this stuff you don't need
to come up with
um
like like science fiction type um
you know ideas to make it intriguing i
mean it's it is it's it's wild the way
it is you don't have to do much to it
have you come up with any theories as to
why cattle mutilations occur
me personally
or heard any that you found to be
interesting
well i wouldn't have any science to back
anything up so i could tell you i'm a
dreamer you know so i can come up with a
bunch of ideas i have some um you know
i've heard scientists discuss
you know tracking our food supply you
know trying to see if there's
things that are in our food supply that
are affecting kind of how we evolve okay
that that was an interesting and there's
a lot more to it but it's not my place
to get into that um i've heard people
discuss that you know it's genetics or
something it's it's understanding
um a bit more about you know the life
here on earth or whatever then you get
into way more far out stuff is maybe it
has something to do with genetics with
man because maybe bovine type samples
deal with you know the blood or the i
don't know like the glands or something
have to do with you know people want to
go way out and be science fiction about
it but i i just don't know and i think
i just think that what we are hearing is
that
people are seeing lights and craft in
the sky in areas where they find these
things we know they're happening and
have been happening for decades and
decades like not just like a few like
thousands you know um but no one really
knows the reason why
maybe someone somewhere in some basement
knows but i i don't want to pretend that
i know because i don't but i do know
people been studying this for like 30
years and and um
and they all tend to say the same thing
it's like it's happening in a way
that doesn't look like we can pull off
what we're finding it just looks way i
mean they found cattle with organs like
their heart missing but no incisions
anywhere like somehow they reached in
and just grabbed it and pulled it out
you know so it's like what does that
mean what is i don't know but it's it's
it's wild for sure
how do you take the reaction in terms of
you know people coming
and saying
you are basically a repository for
people to come forward to come out etc
uh that you know is sort of a unique
role for you tom right uh it's it's now
you're almost like a priest and
confessional and and people coming
exactly
how is that how do you deal with that
pressure how do you deal with the with
the notion of you know kind of this this
you become the face and symbolizing a
lot of this and and there's a wonderful
clip that one of your fans put out on
twitter i saw yesterday or a couple days
you know it was like what you said in
2017 on you know joe rogan show and then
like slowly as they say you know first
creative ideas are dismissed as lunacy
then they're mocked then they're
ridiculed then they're accepted as
trivial and known all along so now that
these you know pentagon report which we
have to get into and maybe i'd love to
hear get jim's take first on that um jim
when this came out did you feel like uh
it answered more questions for me if i
felt like it answered more questions i
mean honestly i am a skeptic i have to
say as a scientist there's no one tom
and jim kurt already knows this that
would be more kind of thrilled delighted
to skip the line as my friend james
altitude says and go from the physics of
2021 to the physics required maybe 2121
or beyond i would love to do that first
of all i'd get you know multiple nobel
prizes second of all i would satisfy the
personal curiosity that sounds like tom
and jim and kurt we all have to
understand the nature of reality because
let's face it guys we're only here for a
short amount of time we're given maybe
the biblical age of 120 that's about it
um but uh but if we could skip that line
avoid death avoid you know interstellar
uh you know kind of have the secrets to
this to these to these advanced uh
technologies and to advance knowledge
that to me is the pinnacle of what homo
sapiens could achieve jim when you look
at this when you hear
uh these complaints and and so forth
people being skeptic do you feel like
skeptics have a point i mean are we just
like kind of curmudgeons and we're just
not hearing the truth uh that you guys
are telling or you know
you have feet in both worlds you're in
the military and the you know government
but you're also in the in the community
that tom's in what do you feel is the
right approach here believe everything
believe nothing how do you split those
uh those atoms
yeah i mean i yeah that's an excellent
question and i think i think you just
said it uh you know believe everything
believe nothing uh i'm i'm not a skeptic
uh by any stretch of the imagination um
and when the
i was not surprised at least when the uh
uh when the uap task force report came
out i i understood what it was gonna be
uh it's just an atomization it was an
outline
of what they're planning on doing
there's no way they could put together
any kind of substantive report any kind
of intelligence assessment based on this
in the short amount of time that they
had and they only took you know 144
incidents my god i mean that's and just
from the navy i
i mean there are hundreds of thousands
of incidents that have happened that
credible witnesses have seen
so i i wasn't surprised
i thought the the the writing in there
was obviously done by the dni it was
very
very well crafted very tight writing i
think they took some pot shots at the
air force which i'm glad they did
because i don't know where the hell the
air force has been in all this
actually i sort of do but
um
but the most important piece i felt uh
was the deputy secretary defense memo
they came out at the same time that was
issued on july 25th
that memo came out and said
knock it off
cat's out of the bag
we are going to go after this we're
going to we're going to develop
requirements and requirements that
basically means that it's an
intelligence term for uh for questions
we're going to develop these questions
everybody's going to have to answer them
and and and and we're going to put money
towards this we're going to put people
towards this that's huge that's
absolutely huge
and um and so i thought i was very very
happy when when i saw that
now
when they talked about in the report you
know they have these these areas these
categories you know about what they
think it could be you know
air clutter and and what have you and
then going down it could be this it
could be that it could be the russians
or chinese
uh look i've i've studied russian and
chinese high technology
for my whole career
this these uaps
or whatever the hell they are i mean we
call them uaps we really don't know what
they are
um they're not russian and they're not
chinese and they're definitely not ours
they're just not
that leaves nothing
left except they're something else and
what that's something else is i don't
know i i i was on tv a couple weeks ago
when i called it
i was prodded by the producer i said say
something say something
and i i called it a i called it a a a
non-human
technology and i i guess
that's the best way i can go
but i don't think science
right now
has the ability to look at this
in a way that they want to look at it
and it's not their fault and i i it's
because you know there's no reliability
here there's no predictability here
uh this this phenomenon
plays with us
it teases us it cajoles us it gets close
but you can't get too close to it
and sometimes it appears to people up
close and personal other times it
doesn't but if you notice with the navy
i mean you know what is it actually
saying i mean you know
are they trying to communicate with us
or are they basically just trying to
affect us socioculturally
uh when you talked earlier about um
cattle mutilations hell yeah cattle
mutilations are real don't really know
what's happening with them
but when you look at what the real
effect of that is
the real effect of that is it's all of
us sitting here and looking at that
and all of a sudden our cultural norms
and and social we if things change and
things change but i know jack valet
talks about this quite a bit and i'm a
huge fan of his
um
are they here to basically change us are
they more of a control mechanism and it
you know
you know and and and the answer is that
we we don't know we have tons of
questions zero answers i think science
has a huge huge way ahead of them i mean
it's going to be very very difficult
um but i don't think we have any uh you
know options except to investigate this
but it's clearly
not human
not not human as we know it yes
kurt you've had jock on what are your
takes and also kevin knows who's a
physics professor
in new york state uh talk about your
peregrinations your explorations of this
phenomenon kurt what have you
uh kind of surmised as a physicist as a
scientist what what kinds of uh thoughts
do you have about
approaching this from the colleague of
as you know our colleagues are very
skeptical of some of these claims cattle
mutilation what does that have to do
with physics what does it have to do
with aliens and other planets and where
would they come from how would they get
here how could these are anyway
kurt my brother tell me what do you make
of your
explorations of this as a topic how have
you been influenced changed perhaps not
mutilated but how has your mind got
mutilated in a certain sense where do
you stand now
well i'm probably much like most people
here used to be a staunched skeptic an
ardent one an arrogant one not saying
that you're one you're not arrogant at
all brian but most are let's say that's
not true that's not true
and
and now i don't know what to think i
don't know if you've played this game
called metal gear solid but at some
points you get when you get spotted
there's an exclamation point that goes
over the guard's head
i feel like that all the time just
constantly what the heck is happening
what the heck is this what does this
mean how does this fit with this
so i don't know i don't even know if
there's one alien species if it's a
subspecies if there are aliens to begin
with if it's multiple races if it's
factions
i don't know
can i add something to the conversation
let me let me give you the government
perspective on this um as an
intelligence officer for a long long
time i will tell you
that back in 1945 actually you know this
phenomenon has been seen since the
beginning of time all major religions
have talked about it
uh we started seeing more of it in the
40s actually during world war ii and
then later on afterwards um when general
twining came out in
1947 and basically said look these are
real these are serious we're going to
have to look at it and then we had
project sign project grudge and then you
know the um and you know blue book and
then
we had all these other things the uh a
condom report and what have you
where they basically came out and said
screw it we're not going to do this
anymore
absolute nonsense there's no way that
the air force or the intelligence
community is going to give up on
something like this that is that is a
very very real
phenomenon that we don't i don't think
it's a threat at all to be honest with
you i just i think it's totally
indifferent to who the hell we are but
but nevertheless it has to be looked at
the military in the intelligence
community does not
ignore that they will not ignore that
and you know and and and this it's
always going to be bubbling up in the
background it may be in some deep black
program some hidden someplace but i
would be shocked and surprised if that
isn't what's going on that we haven't
been seriously studying this
for the last 70 or 80 years yeah i've
nothing because there's no way there's
no way when you look at the stargate
program
that was a direct reaction to
soviet uh experiments in in psychic
phenomena
they were doing that we had to figure
out why they were doing that and what
they found out and i can tell you other
stories
i mean crazy technology to think didn't
know exist but actually do exist
and and you you find out that other
other countries are working on them or
trying them and what have look there's a
huge national security element in all
this too so i mean you know nobody wants
to share this data publicly because as
they say you know you tell your friend
to tell your enemy so a lot of that
stuff is hidden and i i don't blame the
government for hiding a lot of this
stuff either if there is a true and
honest national security uh uh problem
associated with this but you know i i
just find it extremely difficult uh
with skeptics who who who tell me like
when they see this stuff and they go
well i don't know what it is look at
that's agreeable i mean i i don't know
what it is either but it is there
and no one has an answer to it and and
please don't tell me it belongs to you
know china or russia or some other
that's just nonsense i think that was an
out that the uap task force had to use
um um i mean once you've read the
literature once you've been read on it
it's read it on some of these programs
it's just i'm sorry it just i i'm not a
skeptic that did exist i just don't know
what the hell it is you know when i when
i look at that data and you know i'm
going to ask each of you to steel man
your quote opponent's perspective in
other words what's the best argument
you've heard counter to your own
position jim and tom especially but
before i do that i want to just make
take a reset and tell everybody who
we're talking to tom delong of course
the to the stars academy and also jim
simvan of to the stars academy former uh
cia play and kerche mungle host of the
theories of everything channel uh which
has done yeoman's work kurt you're
you're really a role model in many ways
to many youtubers we've got a lot of
people listening jeremy reese in the in
the chat room and many other people but
tom i want to ask you when i hear talk
to my fellow scientists about this and i
talk to somebody who's a member of i
don't know if you're familiar with this
organization called the jason's jason's
are a secret i'm sure jim knows about
them too so they actually meet here in
in san diego uh once a year at least
they did before covet and they tell me i
said wouldn't you think like the best
and brightest would be at least
interested and involved in this and they
said nope i'm not we're not they haven't
asked us the government hasn't asked us
to investigate it we're not just going
to go off and investigate stuff on our
own um why would this organization
assuming he's telling me the truth and
she there's actually multiple people
members of the jason's have told me the
same thing no we're not investigating
these phenomena uh is that insulting to
you how do you take that is that proper
skepticism is that um
in my experience um
in my experience even the people that
are very much involved on this stuff
would tell you that exact same answer
you know jim can explain
security clearances and national
security stuff i i can't i'm not
i don't know that kind of stuff i just
know through osmosis kind of how it's
treated but um
i when i first met a bunch of people
that were involved on this subject
before i even knew jim i remember
specifically
you know i was in
one place and you know there's a big big
wig i was talking to and he goes you
know
um you know we don't
ever look at that subject we don't care
about that subject there's absolutely no
evidence whatsoever that any of that is
even real
yadda yadda and i was like okay um
thanks and then i left that person's
company
uh or that that person's table and went
right outside the door and there's these
other two guys that work directly under
them that said we want to talk about
this and they talked about it for an
hour you know and it was like nothing
classified they can't go there but it
was just like some people are more open
to it and some people aren't but the
people that are
dealing
directly with something that's
classified they're never going to even
talk about it you know um as far as the
best and the brightest i guess that's
subjective because
you know who knows if the jason's really
are or not i've always heard that they
kind of were you know but i think that
you know you have incredible people at
the national academy of sciences you
have incredible people at the national
laboratories you have incredible people
at the lockheed martins and the boeings
and they're everywhere and i think that
um it's not exclusive that we need this
one group of scientists or whatever who
knows if something's been studied for
decades and decades they're going to
choose people that are the best and the
brightest that can keep their mouths
shut because it probably has these big
national security elements that come
with it
and they're going to find people that
bring value in ways that they need it's
not just like a blanket like you're a
great scientist we're going to bring you
in i mean i as far as i know and what
i've learned
you know black programs don't really
work that way but i'll tell you directly
directly direct experience
that
um in the very beginning everyone said
that to me and and because they had they
don't need to open up a conversation
with me they don't need to talk about it
they're not going to get anything out of
it if anything they're just going to get
in trouble or make them feel like they
need to go back and report a
conversation where something slipped or
something so i just don't think that's
the right
route but one would to but what i will
say is i talk to the former head of the
task force uh before it's in its current
form however that works and i asked him
i said what's the biggest change
uh
now that we we were able to bring the
ufo subject out into the mainstream and
he told me he said for the first time
ever we can talk about this in the halls
of the pentagon up until this point you
know it was always in a skiff
underground somewhere you know i heard
similar things from alexanditritch who's
a renowned fighter pilot who's involved
along with uh with commander fraver and
the so-called tic-tac incident and one
very valuable thing that this is
elucidated is the um breaking down those
barriers the the the insecurity the you
know humiliation the the kind of taboo
for military pilots who are you know
heroes far beyond what i'm capable of
doing and uh and they volunteer to put
their lives on the line if these are
military threats or even weather
balloons or whatever uh we owe it to our
war fighters to to make sure that
they're safe and secure so taking taking
away the taboo has been incredibly
important for me kurt do you have some
questions uh from your audience or from
you that you want to pose because these
uh gentlemen have a hard cut out in
about 40 minutes 30 40 minutes yeah
there's this person named red panda
koala tom have you seen the documentary
on yourself
i have not
no a wonderful concise 60 minute
summation of your work in
this ufo topic and he or she
asks what was it that tom was told that
kept him up for three days
oh well i don't talk about that but
there was i remember
um
the i remember having discussions
the company that i keep with people like
jim they just
you know in how and
the the the way their minds what's
really cool about jim by the way is that
i've learned how to parse information a
lot better i'm not gonna ever be you
know
him you know this guy is master spy you
know but but i don't i don't i learn a
lot like i like
learning how to
be a little bit more i'm skeptical with
information being able to put these
things together and think differently
but they're all such
um
really big thinkers and they don't just
grab onto a piece of data because it
exists and says oh this matters and this
means everything it's very much like
forming patterns and analyzing over time
so i remember like hanging out with all
these guys in the beginning and and i
and one of the bigger things um
was just about me understanding the
stakes of this because you come into
this as a and this kind of answers your
question about like what keeps me up at
night or what kept me up when i was
discussing things was not understanding
the stakes not really coming to grips
with this being real like it's one thing
when you when you see a video or you
read it in a book you know and you're
like whoa this is all you know but you
don't know if the video is real that's
why it was so important with the ones we
brought out had chain a title all the
way back to the dod so we knew those
were real it wasn't just like it was on
youtube and leaked um so it's it's the
idea of bringing forth things that you
know where they come from and and you
really
take it from that point forward and
start um getting really good data and
evidence on people's encounters and the
stakes that come with that and that when
when i've talked about this
as a threat you know this is that's just
my words right i mean i would never know
the way the government treats that
that's not my my zone obviously but for
me in my own personal research if
something's been here for a long period
of time and it really is showing up in
people's bedrooms or in front of an f-18
or on a petroglyph wall or in an ancient
text down in the archives of the vatican
or whatever it might be
it's obviously doing something and it's
obviously having an influence and it
might only be an influence on where we
end up as mankind or it might be an
influence
to keep us suppressed in a weird way to
where they can take advantage of
something who knows um but it's here for
a reason and it's not really being you
know forward about its intent but we do
know that we've been dealing with it for
a long period of time and so when you
start coming to like the way they think
and the stakes involved in the reality
of it um and you and i start hearing
about these encounters from the people
that were there
um
i remember in regards to the question
you asked
i was out in colorado springs and i had
a meeting with a couple generals
and we were just shooting the [ __ ] about
all this stuff
um
and something was discussed that
you know it wasn't some big classified
thing it was more like
things that people are are having happen
to them or witnessing and it's an issue
and i remember waking up in the night
just go i i was like you start to look
around you not really trust your
environment you know it's like whoa like
really like this is real like my mom is
a is really religious like she's like a
born again christian and in hardcore
fanatic you know religious woman and
and and i grew up in a house where my
dad wasn't so that's part of like the
big budding of the heads and uh it was a
broken home but i remember thinking at
that time frame when i was um
talking about some of these things that
i just want to discuss uh where i was
where i couldn't sleep very well was i
was like if my mom really believed that
jesus
is real and would show up in her room
and float towards her with a crown of
thorns i mean she would freak she'd have
a heart attack that would scare her even
though she bases her whole life on it
like who she hangs out with where she
goes on weekends and weeknights who she
might date or marry again um every call
she calls me she's praying but if she so
she believes this viscerally but if she
saw something like that it's a different
deal once it's like really real it's not
just reading in a book and believing in
it and that's kind of what i came to
with the whole ufo thing it wasn't just
like believing it it was like oh my god
this is real this is like real not just
that we're talking about it and we saw
it on the news or we saw it on youtube
it's like when you're alone in your
bedroom in the middle of the night you
got to look around and go
[Music]
who knows what can happen and
that's kind of where i've landed over
the past few years it's just like going
anything is possible
does your mom think that what you're
doing is an act of evil or you're
studying evil that you shouldn't be
doing what you're doing she she loves me
too much and it's too supportive to have
that thought so in her head it's like
this it's probably a crisis of
conscience you know where it's like
these don't all map up you know but this
is what i i tell people um and and i
really believe this i'm not speaking for
gem or the company this is my own
personal thing
i i have a feeling
that when we when we really learn about
consciousness and we really learn
kind of what these these things are this
phenomena is i think we're going to like
i said earlier we're going to merge this
metaphysical consciousness type of
science with normal science and once it
becomes all one
we're going to look at we might look at
religions differently but i think
everyone's going to be able to keep the
things they love which is really not all
the dogma and the stories that we argue
about but when it comes down to you know
the father the son the holy spirit or
godhead um your soul and the physical
body it's all the same three things that
trinity thing is like kind of everywhere
it's all about
you as a person with your connection to
consciousness you know the father the
son the holy spirit kind of thing so i
think what will happen is everyone's so
scared that religions will crumble and
i'm kind of like no it's gonna be the
great equalizer that the only three
things that matter in all of these
things is
us as a physical person with our
connection to something bigger and um
and i and so i don't think people are
going to be alienated i don't think
they might you know be bummed that the
story of the locusts coming out didn't
apply you know or something but i think
that the things that matter stay
which is you know i used to go to my mom
and say like you know i'll go how why
are you a christian like why like what
is it show i i know it i've seen things
i've felt things i just know in my heart
but then you know and she goes and we've
healed the blind we prayed and they can
heal the blind that's happened i'm all
but that's happened in islam too
it has so why is it happening in other
religions and here and my whole point
was it's not about the stories it's it's
it's physics and um and people like
yourself are going to help us all
understand that here in the future you
know yeah
so uh so jim antom a question from sarah
skulls who's a friend of mine i wrote a
book they are already here uh about in
part about tom uh she's a she's a
wonderful soul uh she asks about you
know where do things go from now uh and
here maybe uh now that elizondo luis
elizondo and chris mellen aren't part of
ttsa
um how does that affect your mission
guys is that is that you know should
that how should that be interpreted you
know if you were not being you know uh
charitable you might say oh that's a you
know that's a sign they have internal
strife and you know what what but is
there some other explanation or you know
where do you see things going now that
these two very prominent you know
supporters of the narrative uh that you
guys are also you know supporting have
departed from ttsa at least i understand
from jim that you guys are on good terms
but where do you go from here well i
mean
a lot there's so much going on number
one the pandemic here we're startups
we're not giant you know we have we have
more people from the government that
want to be a part of what we're doing
than we have space for so that's not the
issue with those people in particular
when the pandemic hit it really
caused us as a young company to choose
one lane rather than trying to do
multiple lanes and during the pandemic
the defense authorization act they
didn't they couldn't get it passed they
couldn't fund any more
research projects or new companies new
programs and we were a new company with
a new program um so we were kind of
stuck in this like quicksand of waiting
and waiting to try to get some things
off the ground but where we had a you
know a ton of traction was in the
entertainment part where we already had
product selling we had movies coming we
had tv series coming and so it just
created
an opportunity to focus the company and
get everything really streamlined to
grow quickly without trying to dilute
ourselves in places where we can't
compete with a lockheed martin or
whatever but we really wanted to get
these things off the ground some of
these early programs some of which hal
is still chasing some of which like we
still have an open contract with the
government on some of the material that
we got but chris mellon without i don't
want to speak for him but i do know
chris is involved in a lot of things
back in dc specifically with trying to
get this thing pressed through congress
and with oversight and the task force
and he's so deep in it
that um i think it frees up a lot of
time and gets him kind of
away from the entertainment part which
you don't really it doesn't mix well
with the government stuff and jim it'll
be better for you to talk about some of
this stuff but that was what we kind of
found was some of those issues i guess
yeah
that's pretty much it and and um um you
know i think i think chris needed to go
uh his own way as with lou uh they
wanted to pursue other things that that
weren't
quote unquote
focus
i get that completely and they are they
are doing i think it's just an
outstanding job uh both of them you know
i'm just
huge fans we're all huge fans of them
they they were really courageous to do
what they did uh they had their
reputations and you know lou i had met
with before while he was the head of
atip and
i sort of done some unofficial
consulting with him uh early on and um i
just my hats off to him just a great
great man as with chris so they're
they're doing i think they're doing
god's work you know so we're we're huge
fans any way we can help them we
certainly will
in terms of the partnership between ttsa
and the government there was i didn't
actually see this but according to my
friend mick west he says j.j abrams ufo
documentary episode 3 suggests ttsa
might be part of a government
disinformation program that's what i
signed up for i was like how do i lie to
my friends and my family can i just
comment on that first of all you know
that's that's rather insulting it's
insulting you know not only to me and
you know and all the people that work
for the government what have you
you can't have a disinformation program
in the government
it's it's illegal
can't do that um i wouldn't do that
personally i mean i i that's just that's
terrible and and you know you cannot
influence the population of the united
states you government governments can't
do that it's called an operation and you
can't have that
uh it's it's not we we don't do that and
um uh as a matter of fact you know it's
one of the reasons i don't like going on
shows
uh because when people come up with
these questions you know you sort of sit
there and you look at them and say well
if you really knew how the government
worked
um you know when i was in cia i mean you
know when i was in the senior service at
one point i was running rather large
programs
i had lawyers all around me i mean you
couldn't make a decision without making
sure that you were right on the money
and we ci in particular it's a great
organization i mean they made a lot of
mistakes in the past but by and large
it's a very very straight-laced
organization you do not do anything
that would in any way harm a u.s citizen
or uh or uh or the population in general
so that's uh that's bogus yeah i know
okay and i appreciate that so much and
and believe me you know and no one has
more respect that didn't serve at least
than me i mean my life
you know i mean one thing just to
criticize um the government that i do
love and support and that's the best
country on earth i'll say that uh uh
except maybe canada kurt's gonna speak
up about the 51st state to the north up
there but anyway in all seriousness you
know i look at kova 19 and i look at you
know the trillions of dollars that go
from our 16 of our entire budget goes to
the military cia fbi all these nsa we
didn't i remember going to dinner in
2020 in january 2020 my friend told me
you just got an invitation to go to
china are you going to go brian i said i
don't know and he said you shouldn't go
because china's building this hospital
slash prison they're going to start
locking people in because this thing
called covet i said okay well i'll keep
my eye on it i'm not gonna go to i'm not
not rushed to go to tibet anyway i'd
love to go someday but uh but they knew
about it my friend at dinner knew about
it in other words jim and trillions of
dollars of of
and the countless lives that were lost
precious individual lives lost in
america because you know and you'd think
with this huge apparatus uh that they'd
be capable of doing something preventing
something and i don't want to get into
politics i i hate politics and that's
why i'm an astronomer because there's no
democratic comet there's no republican
asteroid right so talk about the
government like could they do could they
cover up something like this could they
do it malevolently as you're saying the
cia's basically let's just call it what
it is you're saying they're comprised of
good people good men and women honest
patriots um how come they weren't on top
of something like covid which was you
know known to my dinner party guests
well you know
let me just say this uh the last 10
years
i consulted with the intelligence
community and i was working on uh
counter biological weapons uh and one of
the uh corollaries of that was you know
working on pandemics and talking about
pandemics i can't tell you how many
meetings i sat in with the government
from people that did nothing
but talk about the coming pandemic cia
has written intelligence assessments on
it so has dia i mean almost every
government agency has come out and
warned
people that this is going to be
happening down the road and it's just a
question of
when but the problem with this is um
nobody listens the government does not
listen the congress doesn't listen and
the senate doesn't listen until it
happens and when it happens they jump up
on the air start pointing fingers it's a
shame it really truly is 9 11 was the
same way we were screaming you know
bloody murder about uh you know about
osama bin laden this is this is what's
going to happen and we think this is
going to happen soon and people just
look at it and you know say well i don't
really believe it could happen right but
um no in many i mean there are a lot of
times where the intelligence community
fails but but a lot of these no we were
not we were right on top of all this
early on
but nobody wanted to spend money
billions of dollars creating
uh say a a a you know a a vaccine that
that could you know help you know
something when when there wasn't one
where there wasn't a when there wasn't a
pathogen out there yet so
and you know the government budgets i
mean like we can have a whole program on
on government budget and how money is
spent and it's usually spent on
quarterly things the things that you
absolutely have to do so anything that's
looking in the future
like uaps by the way you know low
probability high impact events like that
they don't get the kind of
attention they deserve
but you're right i agree with you
you want to ask
some of your viewers questions yeah well
about the government not
participating in disinformation i'm
curious
there's
mk ultra project mockingbird or
operation mockingbird and project blue
book and quite a few others so what do
you make of that and also even if it is
illegal it's not as if the government
hasn't done what's illegal before oh no
no the government has
oh absolutely i'm not making excuses for
the government i mean the government
has done some terrible things it wasn't
until
1976 for instance when the cia was was
held held accountable is really when all
that stopped when mk ultra came out and
and and um i can't remember the name of
the commission but it was uh gerald ford
was running it and uh it
uh
actually gave presentations on it i
don't know why it's slipping my mind
right now but but essentially a ramparts
magazine had a big article on this and
and the and the intelligence community
just changed right there i mean as mk
ultra was a program
you know they were experimenting with
you know with with hallucinogenics
because they thought they'd control
people's minds because they knew that
the russians were experimenting with it
so they were doing it
it was a terrible terrible program um
and it was an awful program people died
but you know and then they burned all
the files so we don't know what the hell
happened um uh and and this this has
gone on through you know
throughout the government and very
beginnings but as the government gets
older and as we learn from these
mistakes things really do get better um
uh so yeah i mean when you look at like
the condom report that was it was a
total whitewashing
total whitewash
and
and they basically came out and said you
know we're just gonna we're just gonna
make fun of people who believe in uaps
and ufos and all this kind of stuff and
that was awful they shouldn't have done
that
uh and it was actually one of the
reasons why
a lot of us in this
these unofficial government workers
decided we're going to go out we're
going to take this private and i we told
the highest levels of government that's
what we're going to be doing
because they can't seem to get this out
i don't know why that talks with them
but they can't get it out and none of
them had any issues with us doing this
they didn't have any issues with tom i
mean it was just go ahead go ahead and
keep us posted
if you want you know and we do
we do and if we ever come across
information we'll share it with them um
you know we're not
anti-government by any stretch of the
imagination but we certainly don't show
for them and we certainly don't work for
them
i have a quick question
are you aware of any government whether
it's our own having possession of
an alien body
are you asking me any
jim or tom
i'm not going to comment on them yeah
i'm not you know i think there's no way
for us to be aware i mean we all hear
the stories we all talk about it online
or read about it online
um you know that's one of the reasons
why we're trying to figure out about the
material that we got so
we have material from a purported crash
in the late 40s we don't really have a
chain of title all the way back then we
do for like 20 years or something we
know there's a lot of anomalies about
the way it's engineered we have some
theories of what it can do there's been
a lot of studies on it the government's
very interested in this piece but if
that piece ended up being real then it's
like well what else was it a part of and
who was piloting this thing was it a
drone was it not i think it kind of
it
gets us to ask a lot of questions um
i have you know i'm i'm under the
thinking that you know if there's things
that have been around here for thousands
of years then there's absolutely the
potential for some of these stories to
be real the problem is is like
you're not going to get anybody to come
out
and just say that
so easily
i think that there's steps to this you
know i look at the task force report and
i look at what's going on now and
and if i
if there was such a thing like bodies or
craft or whatever
um
and they're so advanced and they're
somehow
influencing
the you know mankind and the way we are
engineered to evolve or something crazy
i mean because i look at us now it's
like first we we got into the biology of
our bodies and then we got deeper and we
got into like you know um dna and what
that's doing and every time we master
parts of the body and parts of you know
the world we see and touch and feel like
what's the next thing well i think the
next thing is going to be discovering
consciousness and then we're going to go
how do we manipulate consciousness and
how do we capture it and how do we are
you know so i'm kind of thinking this
these beings have been around for so
long they must be in they must be
so far beyond like wondering about our
dna or wondering about like what our
spleen does i think it's going to be
probably unnerving probably complicated
probably a lot that we don't know and so
the idea of the government just coming
out and saying hey look what we got
before they know what it is doesn't make
any sense to me and i tell my friends
this i go if someone like jim
caught some dude sneaking a nuclear
weapon you know through the border
of canada somewhere into the states you
know are they going to stop and tell us
all about it and really just talk about
it or are they going to go and try and
track down the guy who he was working
with where he got the parts where the
device is got it goes on and it might
take some time now imagine if that
device was like handing an iphone to a
cow and the cow was like i got to figure
out what this iphote is so i think that
the logical steps that one would take
are exactly kind of what's happening
which was
a number of years trying to figure out
something trying to come up with a plan
that helped understand it or whatever
and then it's like okay now let's create
a proper organization to start getting
more data and letting people know that
the data is real and that we need to
study this and then over time being able
to say this is what we learned you know
it's real and now we're studying it and
this is how they fly and it looks like
they might be doing this and that you
know and so i think we're doing the
logical steps now that might one day
lead to
we've collected some stuff you know but
i don't think that if they even if they
did
i wouldn't knowing what i know about
this subject which isn't like a lot i
feel like it's a lot but but who knows
um because they say like studying space
is like if we were to study the oceans
it's like we know a half a cup of water
of the oceans that's how much we know
about states yeah so i just i think this
is i think you're seeing
a rational logical progression of
something extremely complicated starting
to be formed to come out after a long
period of time of digging in and trying
to wrap their heads around it that's
what it looks like to me
and a baby taboo and you in particular
tom you know doing yeoman's work to make
this less taboo to make it into the
public consciousness um and yet i'm
curious how you react to my colleagues
professors astronomers who spend our
days you know i heard um i heard
commander fraver saying on lex
friedman's podcast you know we are
trained pilots we are trained to use our
senses our eyes and our tools and our
technology well so are astronomers we're
pretty good at looking up and things in
space we survey the sky with high
cadence with quite great frequency some
right here in southern california as you
know look out your window and see mount
palomar
but i want to ask you how do you react
to those that say well astronomers would
like nothing better than for these craft
to be real again so that we could bypass
the the line and skip from the
equivalent of euclid 2 000 years ago to
uh to einstein you know uh that would be
a tremendous boost towards humanity and
no one would have a negative state in
that in the astronomical community you
might say the government does uh and
that they want to keep us you know
comfortable and happy and not in
revolution but big astronomy doesn't
exist so how do you react to that that
astronomers would like nothing more for
these to be real we don't have credible
reports in any sensor and any wavelength
any frequency any uh polarization time
of day a year that where it's really
credibly come out and been verified
peer-reviewed however you like to say it
how do you react to those kinds of of
assertions um well two two things for me
and i think jim will have some really
great insight on this um as usual but i
the two things for me are number one
there has been that stuff it has been
picked up that was one of chris mellon's
big pushes is that all of these
satellites that are doing thermal
imaging watching animal migrations
weather satellites spy satellites it
collects data all day long and he's like
we need to scan that data and we need to
find out you know if this weather
satellite picked up um
you know uh
there's a little roman right there you
need something you need to send this
weather satellite picked up something
flying through but these satellites
aren't really geared to pick up things
moving 20 000 miles an hour and doing a
90 degree turn but it still might be in
there but we have to do some software to
kind of pull it out but then we have the
videos that come out there's so many
more videos that we know that are
probably classified not so much because
of what's on it but maybe where they
filmed it or how good the resolution is
or whatever those things are but those
things do exist we've filmed these
things the military has them the
government has them on the best systems
that have ever been created in the
history of man on the spy one radar the
uss princeton and these top gun pilots
and top gun radar controllers capturing
this stuff with with their eyeballs with
the sensors with the people in the
planes all that stuff is there the
second thing is is i don't personally
and i don't know this but i don't think
these are coming from space i don't
think they're coming from deep space so
we're looking
at the oceans but we're wondering where
we're going to find a planet
you know you're not going to find one
there you know so i think
it's better that we're
monitoring you know the area around our
planet and and what things are
materializing in this realm in that so i
think astronomers are looking far out
and i i'm not exclu i'm not saying that
there aren't there isn't other life out
there and they're not sending drones out
or maybe they're got advanced enough to
travel i'm not saying that i just have
this feeling that the universe
is more of a duality structure where
time can extend in two directions in the
exact same
moment in the exact same place which
means people that are very advanced or
things that are very advanced can just
pop over
like a radio station and
that's why we're not seeing them because
we're looking out at mars or we're
looking out at like alpha centauri and
we're like where's it coming from you
know it's like no it's it's in utah it's
just in the future or something and um
so i think i think we're gonna learn and
think around
those lines um and and i think
astronomers are totally capable i mean
these are some of the smartest people in
the world i think maybe it's like adding
to
like their perv it's like adding to what
they look for and look at and where they
look would be kind of cool you know
getting you guys to look at
you know frequency and duality theory
and time existing at one moment in the
same location and you know so it's not
just looking at stars it's kind of how
do you react to the new project galileo
professor gavi loeb who's the chairman
of the harvard astronomy
department for longer than any other
person you feel like that's a sign of
progress that that's being made and
mainstreaming it
um any anybody that's interested in
looking for these things and treating
them as real is is really good for the
scientific community um that's why our
company exists is to like create that
opportunity where the stigma is gone
um
i'll tell you like
i
it's so all the conversations i've had
with people that really do know a lot
about this stuff um
it you know they can only talk about so
much so even i was on the wrong path 50
different times for like years i really
thought i understood something and then
all of a sudden someone else says one
more thing and it changes everything i
thought i knew and i was like oh my god
i got it so wrong and then you know it's
it it's difficult to comprehend
especially for a guy like me i'm not
like you i don't i didn't go to college
i didn't study science i don't have
but that ability but i'm a pretty clever
guy and i could find patterns pretty
easily um and uh and i'm constantly
learning i'm constantly open to learning
um but i just think that
that these scientists and
i'll give you an example i mean i won't
go into too much detail because i don't
feel comfortable doing it but i i there
was a very important person
that i met early on long before i knew
jim and i and i remember that somebody
that was a very high-ranking person at a
very important government place said you
should meet this person he's a very
interesting
person very high ranking person and uh
and i said because i pitched this idea
of what to the stars could be and so
this person comes to san diego they put
me on the phone with this other person
and said hey this is tom and he's got
some great ideas about how to talk to
the youth about you know life in the
universe and so on this person on the
phone was like well there's no evidence
for that i don't believe in any of that
um it's just not my thing but why don't
you fly up tomorrow and come meet me you
know and i was like to talk about what
something that doesn't exist so i
remember this person was putting visit
that you talked about on rogan
no this is something different
but it led to that and so this person
was just like it was a two-hour
conversation none of it's real none of
it exists but i want to hear what your
plan is or what you're trying to achieve
you know and i remember this person was
setting up a venture to look for life in
the universe somewhere with some really
cool technology and a lot of money um i
don't want to say too much um
and i was like you know sir you're
you're looking for life out there you
are
raising all this money and you're doing
this great thing for humanity and i
believe it's out there i'm all but i
i want to talk about the ones that are
here
i think young people need to know about
the ones that are here and i remember
banging on the table you know because i
knew that the meeting was kind of
varying after two hours like you know
it's gonna get shut down i was gonna get
anywhere so i got really full of passion
and i was like you wanna look out there
great i need your help because i wanna
discuss what's here the ones here you
know and then he took a deep breath
and then he just looked at me and then
he and then he said he goes let's
introduce him to so-and-so and then the
other guy next to him turns his head and
he goes are you sure he goes yeah i'm
sure and that's how it led to that other
meeting and the next thing you know you
got these people gathering around that
want to talk about what's here but
they're very very limited on what they
can say so i have to like
kind of put things together and then
fortunately i meet jim and jim teaches
me a lot about how to absorb information
and how to digest it and how to hold on
to it even if it doesn't because it
doesn't have enough about it that means
anything yet but it might be important
later um i'm not him but i i'm trying to
learn as much as i can from him and so
it it the whole thing is just wild like
it's very real and there's a difference
between what's out there and what's here
and it might be there might be a lot
more than that too the universe is big
you know there could be infinite
possibility out there
yeah
yeah i i i just add a quick thing about
science and scientists in general
regarding this uap phenomenon
i feel so sorry for them in many
respects i am a huge fan of of the
galileo project i just think it's
wonderful and i think
what he's going to be doing and what you
guys are all going to be doing with that
is is is really necessary i just applaud
how courageous you guys are going out
and doing that and and dr loeb is doing
that um i i will say
i haven't met very many scientists uh
that are in that are doing something
like this or whether they're skeptics or
what have you that have a really
sound understanding of the literature
and the research that has been done over
the last 70 years on this topic i think
if they did they'd have a better
appreciation
for what they're going against or what
they're trying to figure out um
personally
based on my knowledge and based on what
i know i don't think we're ever going to
come to at least not in my lifetime i'm
an older guy now but
in my lifetime we're ever going to come
to any kind of conclusion about what
this phenomenon actually is i think it
encompasses a lot more than uaps
i think there's a huge trickster element
to it
um
i could go on uh you know but but i'll
just i'll just say that i i appreciate
the fact that science is doing this i
think eventually
science is going to have to
figure out another way to approach this
um
because as tom keeps mentioning
consciousness and what have you i i
spoke to a scientist once and and uh who
was very involved in this and i asked
him i said what what do you think's
behind all this this this phenomenon and
he said it's somewhere in between
consciousness and you know a nexus of
consciousness and you know quantum
quantum theory quantum mechanics but
when you're talking about quantum
mechanics and you know when i ask you
about superpositioning or ask you about
quantum entanglement or the particle
wave theory and what have you you can't
explain it scientists can't really
explain it but it's in a box it's in the
quantum theory box and it's it's a place
they can put it and there's something
there but when you talk about uaps there
is no ontology there there's there's no
right way there's no lexicon that you
can actually use to even begin the
discussion we can't even figure out what
questions to ask about this because we
don't know what it is there's no there
there as i said before
and that's what makes this extremely
difficult and i think that's why
scientists many scientists are extremely
frustrated over this the evidence there
is some hard evidence that i feel that's
hard evidence science some scientists
don't believe that's true but a lot of
the a lot of what we have is anecdotal
and they might call soft evidence but
nevertheless it's there as i said before
these tic tacs that were flying over the
nimitz
they're real they were absolutely 100
real and please don't tell me there is
censored anomalies i know they weren't
sensor anomalies they are absolutely
real so what do you do with that
and so if you're a scientist you say
well show me you know i got to see them
again i got to take this is what i love
about the galileo project i want to take
a good picture
that is the perfect thing to say because
that's exactly what we need we need a
good picture first
and um there are some out there by the
way but um i don't know if we'll ever
see it are they classified the great
pictures
and i think lou's even mentioned this a
couple of times that
some of the evidence that we do have is
rather compelling and and uh but there
is um there's a problem with releasing
them uh regarding some of the uh
uh sensor systems that we have and you
can't give away
you know nicely
yeah i have a question a quick question
about consciousness and this and then i
have to leave pretty soon or my wife
will kill okay okay so consciousness
this trickster element you mentioned now
at the same time there's also steve
greer i believe it's greer who said that
there's a project called ce5 or at least
a
technique of ce5 of connecting
yourself with an alien vs some
meditative technique or perhaps even
psychedelic some trans state some
abnormal consciousness state altered
state
what do you make of this
uh
well i think one thing about well let me
say one thing about stephen greer i i've
never met the man um i do take my hat
off to him he's done some incredible
work early on
uh he's not a big fan of our
organization at all and i'm not quite
sure why
but he isn't
but as far as what he's doing with ce5
and what have you i
i don't have any comment on that i i i
don't go that far i mean it's
tom you wanna yeah my my feeling um
is that you know again if you look at
just what we've done as human beings
over the past hundred years where it's
like we first you know we invent the
telephone and then radio waves and
communicating over different frequencies
and then we're able to tap phones and
we're able to tap you know hack into
radio whatever like you just look at the
progression that we're doing
i would bet money
that down the line when we're
technologically advanced we're gonna not
be hacking radio waves we're gonna be
hacking minds we're gonna be listening
in to what people are thinking
and
what is the loudest that someone can be
when they're thinking i would imagine
it's a group of people that are that are
meditating together they're all thinking
the same thing at the same moment you
know so it's almost like if you're
searching around for a light in the dark
that's a brighter light so part of me
really does subscribe to
um you know consciousness and meditation
and the focusing of one's mind um
is being something that
that something advanced could easily get
into i mean you when you look at the
evidence or you look at the data of the
people involved it's you know you can be
paralyzed or you hear voices in your
head or you know there's it's always
something to do
with you know kind of hacking the system
to a degree um so i i think that that's
all play is a big part of it and uh and
i definitely believe it you know i just
think that it needs to be studied
scientifically
yeah i agree i i don't discount what
steven grier is saying i i i you know it
could possibly be true i just don't know
enough about it uh um uh but
but i applaud that he's actually working
on it but you know
now when you uh we do have some
questions in the audience you want to
know how they can be involved what can
they do obviously project galileo is
privately funded it's at harvard uh what
what about your endeavors guys what
would you like to turn to people to
attention to to get involved if they're
interested in joining this mission well
we created a public company a public
benefit company because a company so our
goal was like if we're going to do this
we can't do this where just a few people
own it you know so we have up for
somewhere between 3 500 4 000 investors
where we let people come and be a part
of this and help grow the company so we
can do exactly this we can tell the
stories we can do the research we can
help push the government we can kind of
become a credible place to discuss this
stuff so that's one avenue support ttsa
you know be an owner of it with us um
and help us get the job done look what
we've done so far on very little the
second thing is i say this this is just
me talking this isn't a to the stars
position or anything don't let the
government um
sit quietly and and just go off and they
say one thing and then we just trust it
it's fine these are human beings that
work there that get distracted that get
overburdened with other jobs they got to
do that really there's not much in it
for these guys
you know that are working some of these
difficult issues to come out just start
talking about it and have everyone start
calling their office and like bugging
them and now they can't get their job
done and now they got to go brief a
bunch of senators that just want to be
on tv and and get more votes but so you
know but i think that people need to not
let them live this down you know you got
to bring this up when they're
interviewing the president you got to
bring this up when they're when the
congressmen are having debates the
senators are having debates to get
reelected you got to bring this up in
the press environment you know when the
when the the pr person is talking for
the dod or talking for the cia or
talking for
uh any place that might have stakes in
this but when we're quiet and complacent
and just read a report that it's all
real but we don't really like follow up
blows my mind i mean it blows my mind
that people are not beating down the
door right now going wait what
this is real how much do you really know
that you're not telling us well in my
own personal opinion i think they know a
hell of a lot more than we know and i
think they have a hell of a good reason
probably for not talking about all of it
i i i because in my experience
with all these government guys they're
all really good people and they're smart
and they're ethical they're humans and
make mistakes uh and new laws get
created for more oversight and so on so
we don't have a repeat of the mk ultra
stuff or whatever but i've met a lot of
these people and a lot of them are just
bound by the the by the ethics or the
rules of how it works it's like they
create a black program but there's no
part of a classified program that i know
of that's ever been spoken of where it's
kind of like okay now comes the part
where we tell everybody about it it just
doesn't exist so then how do you tell
everybody about it i mean jim can talk
about it better than i can but the only
way is pressure pressure pressure
pressure pressure and then finally they
they have to act for the will of the
people and so
that's what you need to do don't let
them down don't let it go quietly
no no and
i couldn't agree with tom anymore i mean
it's he's absolutely right in what he
just said and uh you know this is one of
the reasons we we formed ttsa i remember
i remember talking with lou uh when he
was on the task force and being in the
pentagon and then talking to some of the
officers there uh they were very
concerned about this phenomenon they you
know they knew it was real they just
didn't know what to do about it and i
kept telling them you know look you know
you to go you got to go public with this
and if you can't go public
you know you know we i just formed a
company with tom delong and i said we're
going to take this private we're going
to go to the private sector because the
government does not own this data the
government doesn't own uaps or the study
of uaps or the research it belongs to
everybody it doesn't just appear to
carry your strike groups it appears
everywhere to all people around the
world it's appearing in argentina and
china you know in bangladesh so we
really as as human beings have to get
together and that's when we said we're
taking this private and and we will we
won't discuss classified information but
we are going private the public has to
be more informed about this and let them
know that their consensus reality the
reality we all agree on
isn't
quite right um there's something else
going on and we really truly have to
figure that out because that's what we
do as human beings
well guys thank you so much i'll let it
go with that and i really do have to
leave and i i'm really enjoying this
very very much and i'm enjoying it as
well
yeah let's do a part two jim let's do it
again i'll be more than happy to do it
again with you guys yeah it would be fun
in doing doing and doing another one um
but digging into
not so much you know is it real and what
the government's doing or not but really
just let's dig into
you know what it's you know something
more about what it's about what it's
doing or like something that's not just
government because jim has a lot of
knowledge that's right yeah that would
be a really
yeah the physics implication young
people interested in thinking big look
sometimes it borders on sci-fi sometimes
it has a stigma but nevertheless if we
can inspire just one mind as they say to
take physics seriously to learn and with
the artist eye of tom with the patriotic
eye of jim with the inquisitive nature
of kurt and maybe with a scientist
perspective that i'm trying to bring i
think we're doing a good service so i'd
love to do that again guys uh tom thank
you so much for your generosity love
your work uh thank you big fan maybe
kurt next time you'll take out your
guitar and you'll teach thompson's
chords or something man that'll be dude
i only know three chords i'm in a pun
band i mean we don't know any more than
three so that's what we do oh we love
you man and uh kurt thank you so much
brother and jim it's honor and a
pleasure thank you for your service to
the country tom thank you so much
thank you guys bye guys hey bye guys bye
kurt bye bye
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l
that is kurt jaimungle it's support from
the patrons and from the sponsors that
allow me to do this full-time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you